über ein echtes Bau Desaster im
unterfränkischen Geiselwind berichtete
der Länderspiegel im april 2021 nach
jahrzehntelangen Kampf bekam der
lärmgeplagte Ort an der A3 endlich ein
Lärmschutzwall doch gerade erst fertig
musste alles wieder abgerissen werden
der Grund das gesamte Bauwerk war nicht
stabil und rote einzustürzen Katastrophe
unsere guten Steuergelder Warendorf
erfasst der Lärmschutzwall ist
inzwischen komplett erneuert es fehlen
nur noch ein paar acrylglaselemente was
die Reparatur gekostet hat will uns die
Autobahn GmbH des Bundes aber nicht
sagen wenigstens haben die Menschen in
Geiselwind endlich ihre Ruhe
mit der Ruhe ist es in brandenburgischen
Bad Belzig längst vorbei Anfang Februar
2022 berichteten wir über den Skandal
rund um die örtlichen Stadtwerke die
sind pleite weil die Geschäftsführung
mit irrsinnigen Börsenspekulationen jede
Menge Geld verbrannt hat der Schaden
liegt inzwischen bei 38 Millionen Euro
plechen müssen dafür die Kunden um bis
zu
260%. haben die Stadtwerke die Preise
für Energie erhöht aber die können doch
nicht das alles auf die Mieter
umschlagen wir müssen ausbauen was
andere verbockt haben im Frühjahr prüft
die Staatsanwaltschaft Potsdam den Fall
und kommt zu einem überraschenden
Ergebnis es wird nicht ermittelt der
brandenburgische Landesrechnungshof
erklärt uns er sei nicht zuständig
gleiches gilt fürs kommunale Prüfungsamt
im Innenministerium und das Landratsamt
tut auch nichts keine Behörde will sich
um den Fall kümmern die Menschen sind
verzweifelt den Glauben an die
Staatlichkeit haben wir mittlerweile
verloren wir fühlen uns allein hier
lassen von den Behörden die Menschen in
Bad Belzig wissen nicht wie sie über den
Winter kommen sollen und die Behörden
drehen Däumchen hier schauen wir wieder
vorbei
als wir im April 2022 aus Karlsruhe
berichten soll dieses naturidyll platt
gemacht werden über Jahre hatte
Berufsimker Makler Fontaine eine Wiese
zum ökologisch wertvollen Lebensraum für
Bienen seltenensekten und Eidechsen
umgestaltet aber dann wirft die Stadt
Karlsruhe ihm vor gegen den
Landschaftsschutz zu verstoßen ein
Biotop schadet der Landschaft absurd
wir haben ja ein Biotop erschaffen und
jeder der hier mal im Juni Juli
vorbeikommt der sieht auch mit seinen
eigenen Augen was hier los ist an
Insekten nach einem Arzttermin mit allen
Beteiligten kommt doch noch Bewegung in
den Fall maklerfontänen ist
kompromissbereit erschüttet ein Graben
zu und macht aus einem großen Hochbeet
zwei kleine aber alles kann und will er
nicht zurückbauen weil inzwischen sogar
streng geschützte Eidechsen hier
Nachwuchs bekommen haben
dank der Berichterstattung vom
Länderspiegel ist ja das erst so richtig
medial hochgegangen und ich bedanke mich
natürlich für die ganze Aufmerksamkeit
von den Bürgern
ich denke ohne diese mediale Begleitung
hätte es hier vielleicht ganz anders da
am Ende ausgesehen vielleicht ein
komplett Abriss wäre dann drin gewesen
jede Menge Geduld brauchte man im
rheinland-pfälzischen Mettenheim als wir
im August 2021 über den Bahnübergang
berichteten bis zu 20 Minuten waren die
Schranken geschlossen der Grund die
automatische Öffnung und Schließung war
ausgeschaltet weil es bei einem anderen
Übergang ein Sicherheitsproblem gab
vielen dauerte das zu lange trotz
geschlossener Schranken liefen sie über
die Gleise
das nur eine Sache das was passiert und
das finde ich das Schlimme das wirklich
an der Situation nichts geändert wird
jetzt hat die Deutsche Bahn reagiert und
technische Anpassungen vorgenommen seit
Juli funktioniert der Bahnübergang wie
er soll der Bürgermeister ist
erleichtert
wir sind alle sehr froh dass die
Situation jetzt bereinigt ist dass wir
in etwa die Situation wieder haben wie
vor dem Abschalten der Automatik
2026 will die Deutsche Bahn sogar die
komplette Technik erneuern hoffentlich
klappt das dann auch